so we saw robocop yesterday and uh we're
re-recording
because somebody didn't do the focus
of the focus and we want to be a damn
good professional
show for you people that's right it's
really your fault
blame yourselves for why we're redoing
this so focused on you guys
bastards no we're kidding we love you
guys the customer is always right
what's up miles parkinson oh gave you
your shout out
hello i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry
welcome to reasons to see citizen we're
going to give you some reasons to see
or maybe not to see the robot cop
so let's hang out citizens
reason to see number one the writing and
directing
yeah so no i [ __ ] loved the hell out
of this film i wasn't expecting to
it just looked like an okay sci-fi
action phone when i saw it but it's way
more than that
way way more there's like a total story
to this film man the writing is
fantastic
first thing i noticed was like even the
dialogue sounds great everyone has their
own type of way of speaking
yeah it's just like the characters are
so well defined without being so cliche
and expositional about it i love the
writing
jerry i think it's about time you talk
because i'm kind of just taking over
everything right now because i mean
selfish oh no it's all right i mean i
enjoyed this movie a lot more than i
than i thought i would i mean part of
what i like so much about it is that
it's
a remake that they arguably didn't have
to put much effort into
and yet they really do and they bother
to not make it just to retry the first
movie like it's updated in a lot of
clever ways
relevant to now as if they said how
would this movie exist if it was
new today yeah it's a great modern day
update and at the same time it's
different than the original like the
rotten tomatoes and census says like it
doesn't offer a significant improvement
over the original but i'm like i would
agree with that if they were trying to
redo the original like this
has a different type of plot to it it
feels more like the alex murphy story
well yeah it's like they figured like
how can we make a good robocop movie
instead of how do we make robocop again
reason to see number two joel kinnaman
like sorry no please please no you had
you had a thought yeah joe kidman
he's awesome as robocop and more beyond
robocop he's more awesome as alex murphy
that's the cool thing is that they
really get you to care about alex murphy
like when you see the trailers the
reason why the film looks so empty was
because it looked like oh it's about a
guy who becomes a robot and he's a
badass cop
it didn't look like an offer much story
but like when you watch it it deals with
like the emotional turmoil he has to go
through with trying to adjust to
something so
extreme you you get to see the full
effects of the aftermath of his
accident in this moment like joe kinman
starts to like cry you really
feel his pain and it's cool to see an
actor go to such an extreme level with
his emotions in
in an imaginary sense and to be able to
believe that i find that really
impressive i think people take that for
granted when you're dealing with
something
so fictitious because when an actor can
make something fictitious and believe it
to that degree where it's like
totally not real that is when it's like
really cool not fictitious but like
when it's this kind of movie and when
it's you know like a sci-fi action
fantasy like you're not expecting
people to get as into the the more
character bits and going back to the
script that's what i think
is really cool about their approach to
this one because they didn't just go oh
let's just
action people want action like this
movie has a bunch of moments where
in other action movies i would probably
be sitting there going i wish they'd let
that moment play out and this
movie does do that yeah i thought they
improved on the alex murphy character by
far
because when you think about robocop you
think about robocop but in this film you
think about robocop but you think about
alex murphy as the robocop well yeah
and the thing about like a remake is
like everybody has a different idea of
what they want a lot of people are
complaining like oh you know
it's more about like the human struggle
versus becoming a robot and stuff and
it's not like the original
i'm like well isn't that the point
shouldn't it be its own thing and not
like the original and for that reason i
really respect their choices yeah it
feels like a film that was inspired by
an old film and you know but they keep
like the same names
of people and stuff yeah and they update
a lot of the themes because there's
there's a lot of stuff about you know
like ethics in terms of
in business and you know human ethics
and advertising
and you know the ethics of warfare and
police work and all that stuff and then
there's also the man versus machine like
they give you
much more to think about than i was ever
expecting a robocop remake to give you
to think about
and one thing i thought that totally
made the film feel more personal
was you really see alex murphy as a
family man in this film
and like the struggles his family is
going through while he's going through
this process
it's it's very effective stuff it's a
lot more psychological than ever
and it's very emotional and uh yeah it's
it's great [ __ ] it's
i mean the whole cast is great reason to
see number three
gary oldman gary oldman is [ __ ]
awesome in this film
he plays like the doctor who pretty much
creates robocop
and he's fantastic in this role like
he's barely advertising it but he's such
a main character
and well he just gary oldman has an
incredible ability so good
yeah he has this incredible ability to
just become someone else
instantly like just from watching a
[ __ ] facial expression while he's
sitting you're like i get the guy i get
the guy completely i can feel him and
it's like gary alma's not acting he just
seems like he's being natural as this
guy it's incredible dude well that's
that's a credit to the entire cast of
this film
uh because everyone really feels like
you know some people you can tell they
have fun with their roles or whatever
but everyone brings their a game
everyone's committed
whenever the more plot type elements of
the script they're
you know whenever those get a little
muddy the cast always elevates those
yeah if you think about the writing and
the performance of gary oldman like you
see
these uh struggles of having to
sacrifice his own like morality
in order to make advances you really
feel it and it's done in such a way
where it's not like shoved in your face
like it makes sense
why this guy is dealing with these
struggles and it adds effect to the film
and gary oldman's performance on it like
the way he interacts with like
alex murphy is is he's so compassionate
even when he's like yelling and stuff
you feel that sense of care behind his
yells you know
reason to see number four
keaton michael keaton is fantastic
michael keaton
i'm so glad he's back he's he's getting
more work now and he seems to be having
a lot of fun with these kind of roles
you know i think he might be beetlejuice
again he said
he's emailing back and forth with timber
oh what email account like what what is
like gmail yahoo
uh yeah i'm sure he released tim burton
at yahoo.com no one will ever figure
this one out
hiding in plain sight but he's great
like you can really tell
he's committed but he's still having a
lot of fun with it you know he's a blast
to watch
it's crazy because he's like a blast to
watch yet he's not
necessarily chewing up the screen he's
not cartoony or or in a different movie
like it's just right
what i'm really impressed by that
performance is that one could have been
a very two-dimensional performance but
this guy brings depth to this character
who feels human like he brings a lot of
personality you could feel a good and
bad side to him he's a master
he's a master manipulator and a master
of marketing and selling things
so he's great at it because he gets you
to buy into him very early on it's not
like watching bill nye
where you know it's just this guy's
obviously a bad guy
well then also we're kind of used to
bill nye doing that thing
reason to see number five samuel l
jackson sam jackson man sam jackson
oh man what i loved about this film was
the prologue it's like the setup of the
film but not necessarily it's more
introducing you to the world it's really
clever the way it's done and they
introduce it through
sam jackson's news report show the cnn
of that day
and it really makes me wish he had one
for real because i would i would watch
sam
yeah yeah like sam jackson does what sam
jackson does best you know he comes in
he's like yeah i'm gonna film something
i'm gonna get my paycheck but he does a
good job when he does that he treats it
like a job
but but he just it he gets it done
though well yeah it's like
you didn't have to have samuel l jackson
do this role but i'm really glad they
did but
he does he sure shows up and brings his
a game regardless
yeah it's not like watching bruce willis
in a lot of things it adds flavor to the
film big time it adds
uh humor to it too it was great to watch
he had some really funny moments
reason to see number six jack earl
haley and jack earl haley
he [ __ ] rocks the two man like the
guy's a natural he's like gary olman in
that way where they transform but they
seem so natural at it because you know
when some actors transformed
you could really tell they're doing
something different with gary oman and
jackie earl haley you don't really
notice that when they
do performances you know well cause it's
not always big transformations can be
you know they don't have to be huge and
you know like crazy makeup or whatever
you know
it was like how johnny depp used to be
because enjoyed that was first jack
sparrow
that was amazing and then after a while
they're like okay johnny down
you know yeah these guys they make
subtle changes but sometimes the most
subtle changes are
you know the best he's that guy you know
he don't like robocop
he's that guy who's like you're coming
in on my turf like whatever tin man
yeah yes he's did that he's 17 man he's
great he's very natural he's good to
watch and he makes the guy a little
funny but you still believe him like as
this guy who could actually pull off
like action and stuff
reason to see number seven action and
designs
oh the action the action is fantastic
and that's not the first thing you
[ __ ] think about with this film
not in a discrediting way to the action
the action scenes
make sense when they come in they don't
feel like they threw in an action scene
it like makes sense at this moment for
the plot to actually go there
clearly their first goal with this
remake was not to just make it a shoot
em up action movie which i gotta give
them credit for you know there's not
a ton of action there's like one three
or four scenes yeah yeah but when it is
there you know it's it's merited and
it's pretty rad and they're all
different types of action scenes you got
one scene where he's taking on like a
[ __ ] ton of robots and then you got
another scene who's breaking in
something he breaks into two places but
they're different kinds of action scenes
yeah
and that first time when he broke in and
just started shooting up
with those humans that was like pretty
violent because
some people are people are complaining
about like this isn't rated r
you know but definitely not an issue
it's not necessary for this
robocop tape and then the first robocop
it really is like robocop versus the bad
guys
and this film it's not so much about a
particular villain like they got several
bad guys but they're not even really
the bad guys of the movie except for one
dude there's not a lot of focus on them
and there doesn't need to be this is
really robocop's origin story like why
would you get so against the remake that
is good
over the fact of a rating you know well
because you know a lot that's all stuff
people look at before they go in
yeah and also remake is already at a
disadvantage simply because it's a
remake
and the designs of everything were
fantastic too like i like the robocop
new suit well and they they acclimate
you to it very well because they they
start you out with the silver suit and
then
yeah the way they transition and what
they decide to do with the various
approaches to the suit actually work
really well and it helps separate
the two movies big time yeah well and
also i i found it kind of cool that when
they use the black suit it actually kind
of symbolically makes sense to the story
yes yeah because you know it's getting
the darker devoidness of color
you know ah
yeah you know and it's getting darker
for him blah blah blah jay barrow show
jay barachel that should be the first
reason to see this yeah if you're gonna
build a robocop i don't know if that's a
good impression
no that sounds like paul giamatti or
adam sandler's impressions of everything
i would like to build jammer
um the soundtrack pretty sweet suit
soundtrack man
good soundtrack i don't know how to go
into detail with it because it's a
soundtrack but
its use of instruments was awesome well
it's always cool to hear the theme song
oh and the scene theme song was really
cool too they had a little mix
kind of ryan's consensus jerry i'm gonna
say it
oh [ __ ] robocop is the reason movies are
made
robocop is the reason movies are made i
i like it because like it's entertaining
in a different way like it's a serious
film it's a drama for sure a sci-fi
drama but at the same time it's like
still really entertaining throughout it
moves you emotionally and i think that's
a great
that's a great time in a science fiction
world jerry's consensus
a genuine well thought out remake is the
reason to see robocop
a genuine well thought out remake is the
reason to see robocop
like i said it updates itself in a lot
of you know interesting and clever ways
and it you know respect the original
while also being
its own thing and i really appreciated
them for that because they didn't
have to try and they did all right guys
thanks for checking out our review for
robocop
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below
and tell us which no [ __ ] that
what did you like more about this
robocop film and once you're done with
that once you come over here
click this button so you can see more
episodes of reasons to see
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of our
awesome bitchin possum videos
are out subscribe
huh here's where we usually you know
have a little discussion
we talk maybe make you laugh a little
bit you guys seen the lego movie
[ __ ] dude that movie was [ __ ]
insanely good
yeah oh man i want to watch it again
i want to go like stoned
no i can't keep up with your head we'll
explore yeah i couldn't keep up with
that that'd be insane
you